As technology keeps moving faster and faster,
I amgood with something slower.
My finger beneath the words
has led me to a life
of writing books for
people of all ages,
books meant to be read
slowly, to be savored.
Sometimes we read to
understand thefuture.
understand the past.
We read to get lost, to forget
the hard timeswe're living in,
and we read to remember
those who came before us,
who lived through somethingharder,
who were not allowed to read at all.
They, too, must have circled fires,
speakingsoftly of their dreams,
their hopes,
their futures.
Each time we read,
write ortell a story,
we step inside their circle,
and it remains unbroken.
Andthe power of story
lives on.